[Music]
and of watch yes excellent movie thank
you say they they got me a copy of the
film and I watched it so I didn't pay
you are in amazing shape for this movie
and I say that in kind of I'm attracted
to you now you I don't care it's late in
my life you you've got an insane shape
for this movie how did you do that well
I mean I don't know about like a stay in
shape I we did a lot of training for the
movie did fight training every morning
for the for the movie five five days a
week and then we did tactical training
with with live ammunition and like two
two times a week also you used live
ammunition yes we used live ammunition
why is that necessary if well I you know
I mean we're actors and I think the
director just thought it might be fun to
watch us deal with live ammunition oh I
know increases the chances of someone
dying
it's a rough business what can I say
yeah no I because it's a movie that shot
and you know in it's a very authentic
movie shot and sort of point of view
style and so yes in order to make it as
real as possible for us we really wanted
he wanted us to know how it felt you
know to really to shoot weapons for real
and actually to get beat up also for
real and so that's why I ran fight you
were beat up for real yeah I was beat up
for real not the first time in my life I
was beat up for real budget by 14 to 20
year old kids at a dojo in Echo Park
yeah okay and this had nothing to do
with the movie so wait you went to a
dojo in Echo Park and and and they had
you fight other kids yeah no the other
kids were just sent in to beat us up
yeah that was basically that I was with
no yeah we did we fought every morning
we would go in and we would I have no
fight scenes in the movie but again you
know the director
romantic comedy
in the 19th century that would be
amazing
yeah the way yeah no I we the director
wrote training day he was fast and
furious yeah you know he wrote a lot of
movies that are sort of on the streets
and about the streets and this movie
happens to be about the streets a two
police officer on the street so he just
wanted us to feel you know what it was
like to be you know authentically beat
up you know and to be able to beat
someone up and be able to be in a
situation and actually or that threat
yeah yeah and actually pretend like you
could survive it were you you mentioned
this was not your first fight did you
get in a lot of fights when you were a
kid uh not that many I wouldn't call
them fights I would really be call them
more like I did get beat up yet a couple
times we find a picture of you in
elementary school and I find it hard to
believe that you couldn't defend
yourself is that the record straight
right yes yes that's gangster that is
gangster it's also it's not just
gangster it's also the kid from Jerry
Maguire
I would have bought him I would have
thought that roll that was a great roll
fighting a common head weighs 10 pounds
that's one of the greatest line I will
remember